there's a concept that  [Music]  i don't want to be  uh  an icon  um  i want to be an idea  you know i want to represent an idea i  want to represent possibilities um  i want to represent  magic right that you're in a universe  and two plus two  equals four  two plus two only equals four if you  accept it two plus two equals four two  plus two is going to be what i wanted to  be  you know and there's there's a  like there's a there's a redemptive  power  that  making a choice has  you know rather than feeling like you're  at  effect to all the things that are  happening  make a choice  like you just decide  what it's going to be who you're going  to be how you're going to do